en efecto y horas después de que se
conocieran estas acusaciones y el
veredicto de un juez de nueva york e
inmediatamente el presidente juan
orlando hernández a través de un audio
se pronunció y ha manifestado que la
familia ha reaccionado pues de manera
dolorosa ante esta noticia dijo que era
indignante que jueces y fiscales de
nueva york creyeran en la palabra de
narcotraficantes en este caso pues se
estaban siendo sentenciados también
quienes fueron los que acusaron de
manera directa a tony hernández su
hermano ex parlamentario hondureño y por
supuesto que saliera el nombre del
propio presidente a relucir en estas
acusaciones de traficar cocaína hacia
los estados unidos dejó entrever
hernández que hay otras instancias a las
que acudir a la familia sin especificar
de qué se trataba en las que dijo
textualmente que tarde o temprano se va
a conocer quién
quien en honduras